[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt und
herzlich willkommen in meiner küche
jetzt kommt für die muslime das schönste
monat im ganzen jahr den ramadan steht
vor der tür
im monat ramadan wird gefastet und am
abend wird dann gemeinsam mit der
familie gegessen und für diesen anlass
habe ich natürlich ganz viele tolle
rezeptideen für euch die ich jetzt
anlässlich des ramadans gefilmt habe
aber zum ramadan könnt ihr auch wirklich
all meine rezepte verwenden die ihr auf
meinem youtube kanal und auf dem blog
findet da gibt es ganz viele tolle
rezeptideen anregungen für vorspeisen
hauptspeisen oder auch leckere
nachspeisen
da das fach und rechnen jetzt im
sommermonat ganz spät am abend erst ist
könnt ihr zum beispiel rezepte aussuchen
und verwenden die man super gut auch
morgens oder am abend vorher vorbereiten
kann
murat samira und ich wünschen euch einen
schönen ramadan und eine richtig schöne
zeit im kreise ihrer liebsten horst geld
in seinen guten arbeitet und bronze nach
capulets teams
[Musik]